example yeah yeah because now we see the
ratings I know how many hits this is
getting I see the views yeah
you can't fake those views you can't
fake that's why in a politically Amazon
Prime Amazon Prime's coming on okay you
can fake the views use I don't make any
no comics who buy views on the videos
like no name em nome amen name them name
never you got a name shame my minute you
know guys that buy hits nope did I say
that yes you did
did I or did I not say that and I tell
you yeah cuz I know someone that my real
I know and I'll call him out who Bryan
Callen you think anybody watches any
trash that he puts out whether it's
stand up or on here I know people that
literally put a piece of paper over the
computer so they just see you and they
know how to tune it out so they don't
hear him anymore because it's [ __ ]
trash the fans know the red rocket
should be in this chair all the time
let's explain Kali can we start a
hashtag that says no more Bryan
no no more Bryan please because we're
tired of his [ __ ] lies I was I'm
about to lose 70 pounds in here um are
you gonna use it you fat pieces well one
more no it's up to you doing one more
that's it this line was making headlines
oh [ __ ] Joe Rogan covering Mirian
nakamoto's medical expenses it was like
thirty thousand dollars something like
that can I tell you something you know
badly he didn't want this out really in
the eye jokes everywhere this would
annoy joke to know that it's are getting
circulated around because he probably
did it as a cool quiet thing and someone
was like I gotta talk about she didn't
huh she's the one that I'm sure I'm sure
he didn't love that yeah cuz Joe is the
kind of guy that does does things for
other people not so other people know
about it dude that's a that'd be
homeless or probably killed myself
well then let's that's a bummer that
people can say that a lot a lot a bunch
but I'm just I think about all the
people whose careers now are just
booming because the Rogen hundred
percent do die i Ohio's home I owe so
much that guy because he's on your ten
percent I do not send you guys I have to
pay 10 percent my royalties dude I got a
35 percent mother [ __ ]
nor it no you know what though and I
don't I won't get too into it but I just
think like there are some people that do
things for other other people because
they want everybody to know and it
sounds like I'm pandering but it's true
he does a lot of things for people that
no one talks about that we we know
internally that we don't even talk about
it sexually both sexually I mean you
know perfect look at me look at me hey
once upon a time in Hollywood how was it
great it was right great I can't wait to
watch it so good yeah yeah all these
women are talking about these feminists
I would post that anyone new posting
that stuff just hasn't seen the movie
it's like saying people are like Margot
Robbie to have enough talking links shut
the [ __ ] up you don't know the script
you know you you like write movies like
when she steals the hurt her narrative
steals the movie I mean I'll see Brad
Pitt and did they turning it in the
critic is like a celebration Leo a Leo
like before she went on but I guess it's
a celebration of white men shut up it's
a great movie he's a [ __ ] he's to
quitting Tarantino you dummies
she's a she's delicious he's painfully
hot she's delicious there's three things
that will that that hurt one some
certain cars I see a karmic God look at
the Sharon Tate how beautiful she was
certain girls like oh god damn yes
certain certain shoes like oh god damn I
see I don't have it for cars or shoes
because you know cuz of course because
they're nothing but also women yes
nothing else besides women um when I see
a dude who's built with the way I want
to be built I get depressed yeah yeah
I'll see a guy with like long hair just
a building I'm like hey man like that
yeah but you also want to [ __ ] him a
little bit no I don't rub him down the
wire it admire it you've seen me do that
I stare at them that's weird like I want
to look like that
how come what's he doing with this why
is he Angela yeah Sharon Sharon Tate I
mean what a great cast with Margaret for
Sharon Tate dude there's a scene in
there I'm not this I swear but there's a
scene in there where Sharon Tate in the
the Mardle Robbie's playing Sharon Tate
goes to a movie in uh in Brentwood a
movie theater it's still there goes
there to watch her big on-screen movie
she pays like during mill a day and
she's in but on the screen they're
playing the real Sharon Tate thing and
it's Margot Robbie watching her dude it
is [ __ ] it is so good I can't wait to
see it
Margot Robbie man if aliens came you
would want her to rub Lee the [ __ ]
who I think he'll bundle or what her
some price and Tom young dum-dum he was
not relevant but um she spoiled the
movie she's like this boiler alert and
that [ __ ] review I was like you're a
terrible person what a hostile [ __ ]
it doesn't make them doesn't say spoiler
alert or anything
no she just is a [ __ ] bad person
dude you know Caprio and uh Brad Pitt
[ __ ] man they are so you're on a cap
Rhian that is so [ __ ] guys as good as
it gets and and he's the best yeah the
best yeah I think so now Brian do I
Drive to the addresses that Charles
Manson and Law the addresses in this
movie do I Drive it after I leave the
comedy store and see you guys and drive
by him I fantasize things yes I do
I'm obsessed with the 1960s in Hollywood
you are yeah I don't know why I do that
no that's interesting I understand that
to get a sense of the things that one
does ever want to go bungee jumping
never never me neither one sabayon
no I've never done it why not well okay
so guys you do it no that's one thing I
would you ever do yeah I feel like you
would I would go skydiving before bungee
jump ah [ __ ] he survived though uh-huh
oh that's the worst he survived
yeah there's video yes so luckily and
they have that thing underneath it that
big old the net it's like a bouncy
castle thingy
hold up horrifying moment bungee jump or
plunges down after court snaps yeah
that's right yeah with a bunch of people
watching - what they called the catcher
inflatable like the flavor bounce passes
it is yeah generic cushion dude
pros cons pros I get a thrill out of
jumping off a bungee cord con it snaps I
break my phone okay now high that 307
feet
there he goes and then Oh boom headfirst
ah yeah he's okay he's okay but I mean
he's alive welcome but he broke his back
and he had internal injuries like his
organs were here no he broke his back
you [ __ ] and ruptured every organ he's
fine that looked awful but he didn't
he's okay but he's able to move so he
didn't like you know hold up you know
how terrible is to break you know how
hard is to break your back on America
all right our Christian they're cool man
look like he was falling that fast but I
guess he was oh my gosh yeah under
something fees headfirst look at that
that's where it snaps to can you imagine
what he's going through
dude how about no one knows what to do
they all up oh my god he didn't have it
dope snap just not and he'd hit the very
corner of that bag - how come no one
said anything everyone's either in shock
that's [ __ ] they you know you know
what this is why I don't bungee cord
jump at least he wasn't paralyzed though
yeah so I just guess fix his back for me
and is internal organs and here's my
thing though and for what let's say it
did its that's why wet lowing lowing
it's not work good wool bro cool we
gonna tell about that yeah I don't you a
[ __ ] about your budget me neither
if anybody can bungee jump why would you
do it Oh cuz I felt like I was flat
mm-hmm
yeah well don't well that's cuz of
course not but also does it matter we
should go we should go we should
celebrate kind of Brian towns not here
thank God dude he's not here so nobody
wants that [ __ ] guy around here
anymore no filling in and finally got
Sam Tripp lose that forty guy in the
world I think it's to get you track me
flying I have there much pressure from
the people it's finally happened I live
in Hollywood because of these guys that
booked me and then they call me hey dude
can we move it up an hour which which is
ten minutes from now to go do this
podcast I'm on the other side of the
[ __ ] City they wanted me to get here
like I got some kind of Jeffers
jetsons [ __ ] airplane that could get
here oh no dude yeah you want it I don't
like how bad but also is it weird you're
here yeah you're not yeah how weird is
this want me to talk about all of us
Freddie texted me told me he was like I
can't be there on purpose that's yeah
yeah trips coming in I told me his dad
told him no he's more my favorite lizard
people though like oh yeah there's
something there yeah why do you think is
because he's coordinated his dad CFR I
mean that's [ __ ] great these crowds
are does everyone show up in like
tinfoil some do you know Brooke crusher
pays for laughs you know he pays his
clients laughs you guys I know that
that's a true fact let the Internet know
he he only sells about 30% of his
tickets and the 70% he pays people pays
actors to come yeah man yeah they come
to and he says overlap overlap I was on
delivery person stole somebody's dog
after delivering their package that
pisses me off his fat wiener dog yes
that's the dog I do say what that thing
what do you [ __ ] Jeff little joke that
dog is hey that's a would lovable whoa
no but then somebody loves that animal
bro just like you love your child what
if someone took your your kids not
good-looking what if someone took your
kid your kid is a little good dude like
it'll be you uh get a little refried
mean your kid is a little you're a
little pinto bean someone could steal
him and you and some other guy would go
who would steal that ugly [ __ ] and then
you go that's my kid hey first of all
talk about a fat wiener dog here
compared sons same thing
look at that [ __ ] look at how cute
that damn what they do with them so the
woman who took the dog later posted onto
Craigslist that the dog was on sale for
$100 oh my god neighbors ring alarm they
had the camera system set up when they
found out that their neighbor's dog was
missing they said oh we saw somebody
with your dog does this look familiar
and they realize it was the person
dropping off their Amazon pass shady so
the woman was found arrested and the dog
is returned family should be able you
should be able to beat people up in
public for that you should be able to
use your battery
at public punishment yes let's [ __ ]
floggings like all zzu had but also
wiener dog put up a fight though you
know here's my old fake candidates legs
are so small why they're stupid that's
my point
listen you're upsetting some wiener dog
people dude not a wiener Lappe - dude
they're like the trans there with the
trans your common horse you [ __ ] with
the five people
they show up we don't know how people
come out dude the foot to support their
cause dude I sell out [ __ ] shows dude
just fat wiener dog conventions they
kill and they pay really
[Laughter]